und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und christian sievers
guten abend hinein ein ende der gewalt
in nordsyrien nichts weniger als das hat
us-vizepräsident mike pence vor zwei
stunden angekündigt eine waffenruhe soll
es geben die türkei hält sich für fünf
tage zurück währenddessen sollen
kurdische kämpfer aus einer zone in
syrien entlang der grenze zur türkei
abziehen wenn der plan funktioniert wenn
dann wäre er ein ergebnis von diplomatie
mit der brechstange
der us-präsident hat seinem türkischen
kollegen vor einigen tagen einen brief
geschrieben
das ist lassen sie uns einen guten deal
machen steht da sie wollen doch nicht
verantwortlich sein für das abschlachten
von tausenden von menschen und ich will
nicht verantwortlich sein für die
zerstörung der türkischen wirtschaft
denn das würde ich tun heute twittert
donald trump zitat dank an erdogan
millionen leben werden gerettet aus
istanbul lück wallbott mit voller
mannschaft war us-vizepräsident pence
heute nach ankara gekommen nationaler
sicherheitsberater außenminister syrien
beauftragter der löschtrupp der das
feuer eindämmen sollte dass ihr chef
letzte wochen gelegt hatte ein besonders
warmer empfang war es nicht die
atmosphäre beim händedruck mit präsident
erdogan eisig es gibt nichts zu
verhandeln hatte er schon im vorfeld
erklärt die offensive werde fortgesetzt
verhandelt wurde aber dann doch fünf
stunden lang am abend stellte sich ein
zufriedener amerikanischer vizepräsident
der presse
man habe von der türkischen seite die
zusicherung für eine fünftägige
waffenruhe erhalten so penz die türkei
wird die militäroperationen für fünf
tage unterbrechen damit ihr von
kurdischen milizen geführten syrischen
demokratischen kräfte sich aus der
sicherheitszone zurückziehen können man
habe so penz zusagen der syrischen
kurden dass dieser rückzug der schon
begonnen habe umgesetzt werde
für präsident erdogan war das eine sehr
gute nachricht die von ihm mit
waffengewalt angestrebte sogenannte
sicherheitszone in nordsyrien nimmt
gestalt
an wie es scheint und die usa verzichten
auf angedrohte schärfere sanktionen für
die kurden ist es ein schwarzer tag ihre
kämpfer sollen sich aus ihrem
angestammten siedlungsgebiet
zurückziehen und den türken die
kontrolle überlassen mit ungewissem
ausgang für die kurdische bevölkerung
viel spielraum haben sie aber wohl nicht
die nachverhandlungen mit dem
assad-regime versprochene unterstützung
war wohl zu gering
das regime hat nicht geliefert sie sind
nach man beach und nach telgte gekommen
aber eben nicht weiter nicht bis an die
grenze
die ankündigung von ankara lässt viele
fragen offen
urbane die kurdisch bewohnten grenzstadt
in der gestern assad-truppen stellung
bezogen soll unter kurdischer kontrolle
bleiben so sagte pence in ras allein
weiter östlich druckte heute noch ein
erbitterter häuserkampf zwischen
kurdischen kräften und den mit ankara
verbündeten arabischen freischärlern
dass der syrische machthaber assad die
präsenz dieser teils islamistischen
milizen ebenso wie die der türkischen
armee ablehnt das gilt als sicher
der außenminister der türkei lobte das
ergebnis jedenfalls in höchsten tönen
wir haben dank der umsatz stieg und
führungsqualität unseres präsidenten
heute das erreicht was wir wollten
es wird eine sicherheitszone geben und
die wird von der türkischen armee
kontrolliert nicht begeistert twitterte
us-präsident trump großartige nachricht
millionen leben gerettet
wie belastbar die abmachung aber ist
wird sich am dienstag nächster woche
zeigen dann lauscht die feuerpause aus
und erdogan wird in sotschi mit
russlands präsident putin besprechen wie
die neue landkarte syriens aussehen
sollen
er hat gehört viele viele fragen sind
dann doch noch offen versuchen wir sie
zu klären mit unseren korrespondenten
des trams in washington kommen gleich zu
dir ihnen ist zunächst zur thomas gill
er ist in der grenzregion auf türkischer
seite in der grenzregion zu syrien
thomas guten daten kann man denn von der
waffenruhe schon etwas erleben vor ort
noch nicht weil wir haben vor einer
halben stunde mit türkischen kollegen
telefoniert und die haben uns eigentlich
gesagt dass in russell n also wo den
ganzen tag auch schon heftige kämpfe
waren dass da immer noch gekämpft wird
und die türkische armee hat bewegt sich
auch nicht groß weil die möchte ja
eigentlich sicherstellen dass dann die
kurdischen milizen von der epg auch
abziehen
wie erfolgversprechend ist denn
überhaupt dieser ganze plan den wir da
heute abend gehört haben von
us-vizepräsident mike pence werden zum
beispiel die kurden da mitmachen und
tatsächlich sich zurückziehen um der
türkischen armee dann freie bahn zu
gewähren kann man schwer sagen aber
interessant war das von türkischer seite
sich eben nicht der türkische präsident
geäußert sondern der türkische
außenminister davutoglu das haben wir
gerade auch schon in den bericht vor und
der hatte ausdrücklich davon gesprochen
dass es sich nicht um einen
waffenstillstand handelt sondern um eine
waffenpause und ihnen diesen 120 stunden
sollen daneben milizen der gpg sich aus
dieser pufferzone zurückziehen sie
sollen dann unter anderem auch ihre
schweres gerät also schwere waffen
abgeben und erst dann sozusagen sagt
show soll da erst dann wird dann die
militär operation von türkischer seite
daneben auch beendet und die frage ist
jetzt wie groß wird diese sogenannte
sicherheitszone 30 kilometer tief da
sind sich alle einig aber man weiß nicht
wie weit wie breit sie sein wird um das
problem sind und das kam gerade ja auch
in dem beitrag noch mal vor sind die
beiden städte kubaner und man beach da
sind dem die regierungstruppen von assad
und ob die sich da auch aus abziehen
werden dass dieses thema genau dieses
thema und dieses problem wird dann
solo am dienstag in sotchi zwischen dem
türkischen präsidenten erdogan und dem
russischen präsidenten putin besprochen
also eine ganze menge fragen tatsächlich
noch offen gehen wir weiter nach
washington ihn ist donald trump spricht
trotzdem bereits heute zitat von einem
großen tag für die zivilisation also
nimmt das ergebnis einer waffenruhe vor
weg von der noch niemand weiß ob sie
überhaupt funktioniert und das bei einem
problem das er an entscheidender stelle
mit verursacht hat verfängt diese
strategie bei den amerikanern
man muss sehen das entspricht ganz und
gar eine muster dass präsident schon
immer wieder gerne verfolgt er kreiert
krisen erfährt krisen und konflikte
weltweit an um sie dann selber zu lösen
die lösungen die dann oftmals
voranbringt vorbringt das sind dann eher
nicht nachhaltige lösungen
oberflächliche lösungen doch sie
verschaffen ihm die möglichkeit sich als
großer deal maker als verhandlungsführer
zu präsentieren auch mit blick auf
syrien muss man ja sehen ohne toms
rückzug aus nordsyrien wäre die syrien
offensive der türken gar nicht möglich
gewesen
trump feiert sich heute also wenn man so
will für einen sieg in einem krieg den
er selber ausgelöst hat ich denke es ist
entsprechend kein wirklich guter tag für
die us amerikanische diplomatie trumps
zickzackkurs gerade mit blick auf die
kurden lässt die weltgemeinschaft
ziemlich verunsichert zurück der
handschlag wenn man so will der
amerikaner verliert im moment täglich an
wert auch muss man schauen wie der
kongress reagiert im moment hören wir
eher skeptische reaktion auf die
waffenpause die da nun verkündet wurde
von dort kam ja aus dem kongress die
letzten tage von beiden parteien viel
kritik an donald trump es könnte also
durchaus sein dass der kongress
seinerseits mit sanktionen gegenüber der
türkei weiter voranschreitet also werden
sie indes weitergeht was der kongress
gemacht hat haben wir nachher auch noch
in der sendung nachrichten mit gundula
zunächst erstmal herzlichen dank die
frage einer waffenruhe im krisengebiet
nordsyrien
in den menschen dort wäre es auf jeden
fall zu wünschen das ende der gewalt
denn auch sie verlieren nach wie vor
immer noch ihr leben
unser nächstes thema und noch eine
überraschung der praxis vertrag ist da
erleichterte beobachter jubeln bereits
weißer rauch aber moment moment das
heißt zunächst einmal die unterhändler
von britische regierung und europäische
union haben sich geeinigt unzählige
telefonate nachtsitzungen aktenberge
memoranden das wälzen von grenz und
mehrwertsteuer details all das war nicht
umsonst zumindest nicht ganz umsonst
aber es heißt eben nicht dass dieses
endlose drama um den britischen austritt
aus der eu jetzt tatsächlich ein
schnelles ende findet denn wir hatten ja
schon mal einen deal auf dem tisch
theresa may gescheiterte ex premier
ministerin wird sich erinnern
und dann ging der nicht durchs parlament
das britische exakt das ist auch diesmal
die große unbekannte
und auch europas abgeordnete wollen noch
ein wörtchen mitreden stefan leifert vom
eu-gipfel in brüssel so aufgekratzt hat
man boris johnson lange nicht gesehen
drei stunden ist der brh exit deal alt
als der premierminister zum gipfel kommt
johnston sucht viel körperkontakt hier
ein händeschütteln da ein
schulterklopfen es ist sein erster eu
gipfel und es soll sein letzter sein
wäre da nicht dieser eine große zweifel
ich hoffe jetzt sehr dass sich unsere
abgeordneten in westminster einigen um
den wechsel zu schließen kam diesen
exzellenten deal endlich über die
ziellinie zu bringen und der exit zu
liefern ohne irgendeine verspätung eu
und großbritannien zelebrieren mal
wieder den durchbruch dieser deal soll
es jetzt wirklich sein nochmal werde
nicht verhandelt heißt es wieder wir
haben eine vereinbarung und das bedeutet
auch an wir haben keinen grund für eine
weitere verlängerung juni vor annika des
colombi all das richtet sichern die den
br- exit anders rollen die ihn ohne deal
wollen oder ihn gar nicht wollen wie die
demonstranten vor dem gipfel gebäude
samstag muss das britische parlament
sagen was es will
ganz europa schaut jetzt nach london da
ist nur das bier dem britischen
parlament seine entscheidung natürlich
jetzt zu trauern es ist ein altes
erfahrenes weises parlament und diese
entscheidung für das britische parlament
in vollständiger freiheit fällen und
deshalb haben wir uns mit der frage was
passiert wenn nicht befasst der die löst
das versprechen ein keine harte grenze
auf der irischen insel zu schaffen
nordirland bleibt wie von london
versprochen im zollgebiet des
königreichs hält aber zugleich in einer
zoll partnerschaft mit der eu deren
regeln und tarife ein waren die durch
nordirland in die eu gelangen werden
schon an häfen und flughäfen
kontrolliert das verhindert
zollkontrollen auf der insel
es gibt also keine zolltarife zwischen
jahr zusammen thailand es wird keine
kontrollen entlang der landgrenze geben
das war zentral für viele hier für
irland und die ihn so erreichen wollten
haben wir erreicht
wir haben natürlich alle im herzen dass
es kein freudiger tag ist denn ein
mitgliedsland scheidet aus der
europäischen union
aber wir haben uns immer das ziel
gesetzt dass wir für einen geregelten
austritt großbritanniens aus der
europäischen union eintreten und wir
sind diesen
mit dem heutigen tag einen ganz
wichtigen schritt näher gekommen
ob dieser heutige tag geschichte schrieb
wird man erst samstag wissen wenn london
gesprochen hat neuer deal altes problem
wiedervorlage nicht ausgeschlossen
und auch bei diesem wichtigen thema
bringen wir unsere korrespondentin in
aller welt mit dazu in diesem fall in
brüssel und in london zunächst alle in
brüssel
unterm strich vielleicht mal wer ist
denn da jetzt auf wen zugegangen ich
würde sagen beide seiten sind
aufeinander zugegangen sei johnston vor
ungefähr einer woche beschlossen hatte
dass er doch dringend einen deal mit der
eu will
seitdem waren plötzlich kompromisse
möglich die vorher undenkbar schienen ab
da hatte boris johnson plötzlich kapiert
dass wenn er nordirland wirtschaftlich
abkoppelt von der eu dass das dann
unweigerlich eine harte grenze nach sich
zieht ab da hat auch brüssel kapiert
dass offenbar von den briten nicht mehr
zu erwarten ist für naturland nordirland
als eben dieser zwitter status halt drin
halb draußen der es jetzt geworden ist
also beide seiten wollten dringend einen
deal es gab den entsprechenden zeitdruck
das entsprechende drama und da war die
einigung plötzlich da also es gibt die
einigung es gibt den deal aber es gibt
eben noch kein us des britischen
unterhauses diana zimmermann london ist
irgendwie vorhersehbar was das parlament
sagen wird dass weise parlament ist noch
im selbstfindungsprozess und was
abzusehen ist dass es wahnsinnig knapp
wird gut für gottes kotzen ist dass
diese praxis befürworter seiner eigenen
partei diejenigen die theresa may das
leben so schwer gemacht haben jetzt auf
seine seite zu kommen scheinen einfach
weil sie boris johnson vertrauen dass er
einen sehr viel härte härteren braig
sieht auch langfristig durchziehen wird
schlecht für ihn ist das die
nordirischen unionisten diejenigen die
die regierung eigentlich stützen sollten
dabei bleiben dass sie für diesen deal
nicht stemmen stimmen können eben weil
er einen sonderstatus für nordirland
vorsieht
selbst wenn johnson aber die komplette
konservative partei auf seiner seite
hätte würden ihm immer noch stimmen
fehlen und die muss er bei labour suchen
bei abgeordneten der opposition deren
wahlkreise deutlich für den exit
gestimmt
haben und die befürchten müssen
abgewählt zu werden wenn sie diese
erwartungen enttäuschen
am ende wird es tatsächlich um eine
handvoll von stämmen gehen und dann
müssen wir vielleicht mit in beiden noch
kurz aufs datum gucken 31.10
das ist in knapp zwei wochen da sollte
der austritt eigentlich stattfinden
kurze einschätzung erst nach london ist
das noch zu halten das datum
es ist zu halten wenn am samstag das
parlament ja sagen sollte wenn es nein
sagt dann läuft die regierung zwar hier
immer noch herum und droht damit dann
eben ohne diese am 31.10 auszutreten
aber die gesetzeslage ist glasklar wenn
es keinen vom parlament verabschiedeten
deal gibt und das parlament nicht
plötzlich dem boris johnson gestattet
ohne die ihn auszutreten was es nicht
tun wird dann muss er in brüssel um eine
verlängerung bitten
das wird er demonstrativ ungerne tun
aber trotzdem tun und anne brüssel wird
dann wie antworten brüssel die staats
und regierungschefs haben heute auch
ohne boris johnson schon zusammen
gesessen und garantiert genau über
dieses szenario geredet sie haben uns in
den pressekonferenzen danach leider
nicht sagen wollen zu welchem schluss
sie gekommen sind aber wir vermuten mal
dass wenn die eu die wahl hat zwischen
einem chaos bei exit und einer nähe
einer weiteren verlängerung dass sie
dann nicht lange nachdenken wird müssen
sondern dass sie dann sich für eine
weitere verschiebung des praxis
entscheidet wieder viel gelernt ganz
herzlichen dank nach brüssel und nach
london und damit noch mal zurück zur
syrien politik des us-präsidenten ein
echter waffenstillstand muss für donald
trump auch deshalb so wichtig sein weil
es zu hause eine revolte des parlaments
gibt anders kann man das nicht nennen
das repräsentantenhaus hat quer durch
beide parteien mit großer mehrheit
trumps befehl kritisiert die us-truppen
aus nord syrien abzuziehen was zu einem
zwischenfall im weißen haus führte bei
dem sich beide seiten nicht mal mehr
einigen können welche beleidigungen
genau benutzt wurden
mehr dazu von gundula ja wegen der
syrien politik ist es im weißen haus in
washington zum eklat gekommen
ein gespräch von us-präsident trump mit
seiner demokratischen gegenspielerin
nancy pelosi wurde vorzeitig abgebrochen
in der diskussion über den rückzug der
usa
aus nordsyrien hatte tranquillo sie als
drittklassige politikerin bezeichnet
daraufhin verließ pelosi gemeinsam mit
fraktionskollegen der demokraten das
weiße haus im nachgang twitterten pelosi
und trump bilder von dem abgebrochenen
gespräch und kritisierten sich
gegenseitig der katalanische
regionalpräsident tor hat erneut mit
einem abspaltung referendum gedroht als
reaktion auf die harten urteile des
obersten gerichts spaniens gegen mehrere
separatistenführer diese abstimmung
solle so tor noch in den nächsten zwei
jahren stattfinden
auch heute den vierten tag in folge
gingen wieder tausende menschen für die
unabhängigkeit auf die straße dieses mal
sind es studenten
bislang wurden mehr als 300 menschen bei
krawallen am rande der demos verletzt
ein generelles tempolimit von 130 auf
deutschen autobahnen wird es vorerst
nicht geben
der bundestag lehnte in einer
kontroversen debatte einen
entsprechenden vorstoß der grünen ab mit
498 zu 126 stimmen
die befürworter argumentierten mit mehr
verkehrssicherheit weniger unfalltoten
und einem niedrigeren ausstoß von co2
gegner der begrenzung mit der so
wörtlich benötigen totalüberwachung und
eine bevormundung der bürger in der eu
ist deutschland das einzige land ohne
generelles tempolimit auf autobahnen in
den digitalen netzwerken macht gerade
ein gedicht des comedians reimann-perez
die runde es heißt bei hitlers brennt
noch licht
es endet so vernunft wo bist du wo komm
raus und hilf und schallte es aus sonst
brennt es lichterloh
der bundestag hat heute debattiert über
ein thema das wehtut der hass auf juden
und alles jüdische und dass bürger in
deutschland 2009 10 das gefühl haben
müssen nicht mehr sicher zu sein weil
sie juden sind eine woche nach halle
zeigten sich alle parteien bestürzt auch
vertreter der afd
aber es gab auch bestürzt über die afd
heike slansky
der bundestag gedenkt der opfer von
halle eine kurzfristig anberaumte
debatte zur bekämpfung des
antisemitismus bundestagspräsident
schäuble setzt den ton
die überwältigende mehrheit der menschen
in unserem lande empfinde den anschlag
von alles so wie es unser
bundespräsident bezeichnet hat als
schande
nach der betroffenheit der trauer und
dem leid sollen nun taten folgen mehr
schutz für synagogen mehr prävention
verfolgung vom hass im netz das sich
nicht in der anonymität des netzes
verstecken können dass sie mit
verfolgung rechnen müssen dass ihnen
strafen drohen meine damen und herren es
folgt ein hitziger schlagabtausch denn
ein tweet sorgt für empörung verbreitet
von einem afd abgeordneten wenn afd
brand nur twittert warum vor moscheen
und synagogen herum gelungen wird wenn
doch die opfer deutsche waren dann
verhöhnen sie in einer unglaublichen
weise die opfer alle gegen die afd doch
der fraktionschef wird sich ein mitglied
der bundesregierung sagen kann die afg
sei der politische arm des
rechtsterrorismus entschuldige ich mich
hierfür nichts da müssten sie damit
einfach zu uns vorsitzende und heutige
mit hat das ist sich hinzustellen und
angesichts der opfer von halle und der
angst in der synagoge in halle und der
angst die in diese stadt ist und die in
diesem ganzen land ist bei jüdinnen und
juden
der hat es fertiggebracht ausgerechnet
die von der htw es opfer darzustellen
das ist möglich stunden später hat
immerhin der abgeordnete brandner der
asd mit dem tweet ein einsehen und
entschuldigt sich
es tut mir leid insoweit diesen ritt wie
twitter diesen kredite zu haben mit
diesen folgen vielen dank das
bundeskriminalamt warnte bereits vor
halle vor einem besorgniserregenden
anstieg von antisemitischen straftaten
der bundesinnenminister verspricht ich
werde die ganze bundesregierung alles
dafür tun dass juden in unserem lande
ohne bedrohung und ohne angst leben
können das versteckt sich hinter dem
haus nie wieder
[Applaus]
morgen will segen für seine maßnahmen
zur bekämpfung des rechtsextremismus mit
den innenministern der länder auf einer
sondersitzung besprechen
unser nächstes thema das wird spannend
sagen die einen das wird eine
zitterpartie sagen die anderen die wahl
in thüringen ist in zehn tagen und sie
wird kopfzerbrechen bereiten
wenn wir uns das ganz frische
zdf-politbarometer angucken dann gibt es
keine klaren mehrheiten mehr
wenn schon am nächsten sonntag gewählt
würde sie ist folgendermaßen aus die cdu
käme auf 26 prozent die linke auf 27 die
spd auf 9
die hfg würde 20 prozent der stimmen
bekommen die grünen 8 und die fdp 5 das
heißt die bisherige rot rot grüne
landesregierung hätte keine mehrheit
mehr regierungschef bodo ramelow muss
das interessieren
anders als die wahlergebnisse in sachsen
und brandenburg bei denen er schon mal
so tat als würde er sie ausblenden
die waren für seine linkspartei
desaströse ramelow war eine sensation
als er vor fünf jahren ministerpräsident
wurde der erste aus der linken
mittlerweile ist er für seine partei so
etwas wie die letzte chance aus erfurt
andreas postel mein name ist bodo
ramelow ich komme als regierungschef
jetzt öfter und das ganze fünf jahre
nun tritt er wieder an will sich vom
wähler bestätigen lassen dass er es
gepackt hat der zuweilen aufbrausende
choleriker hat sich selbst diszipliniert
als chef von rot rot grün
der ministerpräsident hat auf jeden fall
das händchen dafür unterschiedliche
positionen auch am kabinettstisch wenn
es sich verhakt hat zueinander zu
bringen und schwächen kenne ich wenn es
brenzlig wird höchstens dass er auch mal
laut werden kann aber das ist halt die
authentizität der gewerkschafter von
einst hat sich eingearbeitet in die
rolle des landesvaters präsidial
selbstbewusst vertreter den freistaat
thüringen sicher auf internationalem
parkett
viele ministerpräsidenten agieren
präsidial das ist nicht ungewöhnlich sie
versuchen auf den amtsbonus zu setzen
auch sich von ihrer partei abzusetzen da
macht er keine ausnahme er musste aber
vor dem hintergrund der aspekte wie er
ins amt kam der vorbehalte gegenüber der
linken sich auch ganz gezielt von der
partei absetzen und seine partei hat ihn
gewähren lassen hinter bodo ramelow
wurden die altkader der sed fast
unsichtbar aber auch 30 jahre nach dem
ende der ddr steht bodo ramelow immer
noch im minenfeld der unrechtsstaats
debatte bei der frage ob die ddr ein
unrechtsstaat war kann man ganz deutlich
sehen dass ramelow noch nicht verstanden
hat dass wir in freiheit gelebt haben
doch selbst angehörige von sed opfern
wie matthias domaschk bescheinigen bodo
ramelow dass er sich mit dem thema
glaubhaft auseinandergesetzt hat er ist
auf mich zugekommen und hat gefragt ob
er mit mir zusammen beten da am grab von
matthias domaschk
und er hat erzählt was er was ihm alles
klar geworden ist oder klarer geworden
ist und ich nehme ihm das auch ab
ramelow überrascht mit vielen facetten
der linke christ der westdeutsche aus
der wirtschaftsfreundliche genosse
vorhaben ja viele wirtschaftsbetriebe
gesagt wenn die linke reagiert dann
verlegen und wand firmensitz in
angebundenes länder ist ja nicht
passiert also kurze zeit darauf gab es
ja sogar stimmen die gesagt haben oder
das ist ein guter mindestpreise für die
wirtschaft ja ich bin kein linker wähler
ich komme aus der ddr-zeit ich möchte
das nicht mehr aber als mensch ist nicht
verkehrt als mensch twitter viel und
emotional als spitzenkandidat ruft die
linke ramelow oder barbarei von der
polarisierung gegen eine starke afd
meint auch in thüringen der amtsinhaber
zu profitieren
und trotzdem wird es wohl knapp
vielleicht versuchte wenn es gar nicht
anders geht eine minderheitsregierung zu
bilden ein schwieriges experiment aber
damit kennt sich bodo ramelow hieraus
normal graz und aussichten für die
deutsche wirtschaft
die bundesregierung hat ihre
konjunkturprognose für das kommende jahr
deutlich gesenkt erwartet werden nur
noch ein wachstum von 1,0 prozent
erklärte bundeswirtschaftsminister
altmaier
hintergrund sei die schwächere
weltwirtschaft im frühjahr war die
bundesregierung noch von einem plus von
1,5 prozent ausgegangen
eine abschwächung der globalen
wirtschaftsleistung sieht auch der
internationale währungsfonds der iwf
senkte kurz vor seiner jahrestagung
seine prognose auf 3 prozent wachstum
der weltwirtschaft in diesem jahr der
iwf tag zum ersten mal mit neuer chefin
valerie haller mit welchen forderungen
trat die bulgarin georg er war denn an
ja sie hat so einige forderungen aber
ihre wohl drängendste derzeit dürfte die
sein
die usa und china sollen nämlich einfach
ihren handelsstreit beilegen die
konjunkturerholung im kommenden jahr sei
sonst in gefahr es gebe signifikante
risiken deutschland ist wegen seiner
starken export industrie besonders
betroffen
es ist georgi etwas erster großer
auftritt als neue iwf-chefin in
washington zur herbsttagung zusammen mit
der weltbank begrüßt sie finanzminister
notenbanker und bankenchefs aus fast 200
ländern
die 66 jährige bulgarin leitet den iwf
sei
anfang oktober als chefin der weltbank
hat sie so manche krise gemeistert
erfahrung die sie schon bald brauchen
könnte
der handelsstreit werde schon dieses
jahr weltweit viel wachstum kosten
prophezeit sie dann müsse die politik
handeln und anreize schaffen sagt die
iwf-chefin auch an deutschland hat sie
diesen appell schon gerichtet die
bundesregierung solle deutlich mehr
investieren um die wirtschaft
anzukurbeln
noch ein blick auf den dax der endete -
trotz drecks it einigung die wurde zwar
mit einem kurzen freudensprung quittiert
dann jedoch die einsicht dass der deal
noch längst nicht in trockenen tüchern
ist und die hängepartie erstmal weiter
geht
vielen dank ballerina frankfurt wer
künftig sonntags frische brötchen kaufen
möchte kann sich dafür noch mehr zeit
lassen
das hat der bundesgerichtshof
klargestellt verfügt die bäckerei über
ein angeschlossenes kaffee darf auch
länger als drei stunden lang verkauft
werden solche bäckerei cafés gelten
juristisch als gaststätte und dürfen
somit brot und brötchen von früh bis
spät abgeben auch sonntags die gute
nachricht zum schluss jetzt haben wir
noch eine eilmeldung die gerade
hereinkommt danach wollen die kurdischen
kräfte die von den amerikanischen vize
präsidenten und dem türkischen
präsidenten heute abend ausgehandelte
waffenruhe akzeptieren und auch befolgen
das hat ein kommandeur der kurdischen
milizen im kurdischen fernsehsender
gesagt damit steigt also die chance dass
es zumindest eine chance gibt auf ein
ende der gewalt in nordsyrien über die
türken die amerikaner in syrien haben
wir viel geredet in dieser sendung
erdogans krieg wie machtlos ist europa
die frage fehlt noch
und die stellt gleich maybrit illner
direkt nach uns und von uns beiden
vielen dank für ihr interesse
schönen abend noch
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren wir
jetzt im oktober noch einmal so ein
bisschen sommertemperaturen nachtanken
will ist eigentlich immer am mittelmeer
gut aufgehoben so auch morgen dort
liegen die temperaturen bei 25 bis 30
grad und daran ändert sich bis anfang
nächster woche erstmal nur wenig aber
über spanien und portugal da wird es
doch deutlich kälter da liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen am dienstag nur noch
so bei 15 bis 20 grad ist gleichzeitig
in tunesien noch mal wärmer wird da
steigen die werte dann bis 35 grad eher
mild sind die temperaturen bei uns auch
in dieser nacht mit 13 bis 6 grad dazu
fällt häufig regen vor allen dingen
nordosten dann gibt es eine kurze
regenpause bevor dann in der zweiten
nachthälfte wieder neuer regen von
frankreich heran kommt morgen vormittag
ist es dann vor allen dingen der
osthälfte freundlich zwischen rügen und
dem alpenrand kommt die sonne gute stube
anders sieht es im westen aus da regnet
und diese dichteren wolken die erreichen
bis zum nachmittag dann auch den osten
und im nordwesten kann es auch kräftig
gewitter
westlich des rheins allerdings lockern
die wolken auf und bis zum abend frischt
der wind böig auf sturm beraten wie zb
über dem ärmelkanal über den
niederlanden und auch über der nordsee
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 13 grad in der eifel und 21
grad im altenburger land und in den
nächsten tagen geht es ganz ähnlich
wechselhaft weiter
dabei wird es vor allen dingen am
samstag im südwesten kräftig regnen
schönen abend noch